the street side gloom in barnsley town
centre
is well matched to the mood behind the
shutters
carl's business is hanging on but only
just
he now relies on online sales and
government support but survival is still
a fine line as long as i can keep a high
street presence i will
but i think if there was no grants
available
for the high street then i would be
closed
like many have many businesses here are
council tenants many
needed this help but support has come at
a heavy price
at least 19.7 million pounds has been
lost by english councils supporting
their business tenants
such as with rent holidays and a further
5.8 million
as a result of company voluntary
arrangements or cbas
these allow failing firms to renegotiate
debt in this case rent
to avoid insolvency the fear is that
loss of sustained so far will only
scratch the surface of those still to
come
and all of this comes off the back of 10
years of austerity
and cuts places like barnsley already
have fewer libraries fewer family
centres
fewer street services many say there
isn't much left to cut
losses here were the worst in the
country two million by mid-november
alone
the council leader says more pain is
probable
over ten years we've made about 120
million cruz of the coats
next year we've defined another seven
million so just when we thought we were
getting out of austerity things were
beginning to bottom out
coverts come along the only way you're
going to deal with that
if the government doesn't come up with
more money we've got to cut services
in order to meet that gap
and it's communities who'll suffer
charlotte's charity receives funding
from the council to support some of
barnsley's most vulnerable families
a vibrant place with a vital role where
small cuts
make big differences it's a bit like
playing jenga
you can take a few away families survive
but if you take enough of those
little slithers of support it collapses
we go back to a time
where unemployment is normalized we go
back to a time where people are solely
reliant on benefits
we go back to a time where people are
living in poverty
are you are you worried about the next
few years hugely worried we are a pretty
resilient crew around barnsley
you know we've been through quite a lot
but you can only chip away
so much given the importance of funds
there's anger too
over cvas some say large companies are
using these insolvency arrangements
unnecessarily
to reduce their rent and rates they are
taking advantage of the legislation and
the way it's currently framed
in order to write tear up leases walk
away from obligations freely
entered into at our expense
in health terms we may be nearly through
the worst but the economic crisis is
just beginning
and crippled companies have consequences
helen and smith sky news in barnsley